Richard Clarke's book the scorpions gate
at the top of this book it says that
sometimes you can tell more truth
through fiction mr. Clark what is that
truth you're trying to tell bill there
are several one of them has to do with
the effect on our foreign policy and on
our national security policy that is
caused by our dependence on foreign oil
and the fact that that's only going to
get worse as China and other countries
increase their demand for foreign oil as
well do you would you be surprised if
Saudi Arabia was taken over by a
fundamentalist group in the next 10
years no I don't think any experts on
Saudi Arabia would be that doesn't mean
it's going to happen although in the
novel scorpions gate it does happen
scorpions gate is not meant to be
predictive it's a future five years from
now in which some existing trends have
been extrapolated including instability
in Saudi Arabia but it's meant to let
the reader think about the problems that
we may face in the next five years
before they happen who is Brian Douglas
Brian Douglas in the novel is a British
spy and he's British because frankly CIA
doesn't do a very good job of spying and
yet the British do with fewer people and
a lot less money they produce a lot
better results particularly in the
Middle East so in scorpions gate Brian
Douglas is a British spy who has to go
behind the lines to reactivate a spy
network is it fair to say that the
Secretary of Defense and the president
don't come off too well in your book
well the president never appears in the
book and it's also not clear who the
president is because it's 2010 or 2011
it's that he's referred to he's referred
to a couple of times but he doesn't
appear and or she whoever it is it's the
president after the incumbent
but again to the question that would you
would you say that they don't the
Secretary of Defense then does not come
off too well I think that's certainly
true of the Secretary of Defense he is a
character in the book who appears from
time to time he's motivated by things
that some people will agree with and
identify with he's motivated by the
desire to have the United States have a
secure source of least and oil and he's
willing to do almost anything the ends
justify the means
he's willing to do almost anything to
keep the oil flowing to the United
States is that character based on anyone
in particular
no none of the characters in the book
are meant to be real people they may
share characteristics with a series of
real-world people there in that extent
they're composites but what it's meant
to be is a way of projecting the reader
into these closed-door meetings into
these command posts places where they've
never been meetings where they've never
been so they can see what it's like in
the Pentagon in the Middle East when
these crises happen Richard Clarke has
written a novel the scorpions gate time
for a few phone calls Los Angeles you're
on the air go ahead mark how you doing
today
very good sir how are you good now I've
noticed that you've been quite critical
President Bush correct
I've been quite critical of his policies
on terrorism and homeland security and
Iraq okay I understand that but here's
one thing I have with you and people
like you even though I do respect your
intellect and I respect your service to
the country you're in Miami right now
correct but me you're and hit that book
fair your ad is in Miami
correct yes sir you know there's a
NASCAR race not far from you going on
right very shortly
from right now okay what's the point of
that Oh what the point is I don't think
you understand middle America partner
does I'll tell you those people there's
that's middle America they love George W
Bush his policies ain't perfect but I
don't care how many books you write how
critical you are middle America likes
him well that's fine
middle America re-elected him all I'm
saying is that middle America and the
rest of America needs to know the facts
so they can make informed judgments
because there are very decisions being
made there defect the lives of millions
of people and you may agree with those
decisions but you need to know the basis
on which they were made
Indianapolis good afternoon you're on
book TV with Richard Clarke good
afternoon good afternoon mr. Clarke
hi in if I could to the last guest that
c-span had on mr. Goldberg I just
finished reading his book and I've read
your book against all enemies I haven't
read your new book but I enjoyed your
first book very much and can you talk
briefly about the demonization I heard
you on National Public Radio talking a
bit about what you went through after
you came out with the book and then you
know going before the 9/11 Commission
and in mr. Goldberg look he's highly
critical of many people that I admire
and think are great Americans in
particular Jimmy Carter who I think has
just been a national treasure as I do
think you are sir and I would just like
to
you maybe comment on what it's like with
somebody who puts out a book of the
hundred people who are screwing up
America I don't know if you're on that
list
I'm surprised if you wouldn't be in mr.
Goldberg sighs so could you just maybe
comment about what you went through
after coming out with the book and going
before the 9/11 Commission well what
happens now I think in our public
dialogue our public discourse is that if
you criticize the Bush administration
though you disagree with the Bush
administration that their propaganda
machinery both official White House
propaganda machinery and their informal
party machinery criticizes you as a
person rather than discussing the ideas
this happened to the secretary of the
Treasury Paul O'Neill it happened to
ambassador Joe Wilson and this week
unbelievably it happened to congressman
Murtha who was a Democrat who has two
Purple Hearts the bronze star who served
in the marine corps for over thirty
years and when he had the temerity to
disagree with the Iraq war policy he was
called a coward and you know I think we
need to get back to a more civil
dialogue in this country where you and I
can disagree vehemently about the facts
or about our analysis of the facts but
we don't need to go after each other and
attack people's motives or attack
people's background and it's ludicrous
by the way when you attack someone like
mirtha and say he's he's a coward when
he actually was in combat unlike the
people who are saying that he's a coward
I think it's ludicrous when you attack
someone like former Senator Max Cleland
of Georgia and say he's not patriotic
when he lost three of his four limbs
fighting for the United States mr. Clark
did you work with John Murtha and Duncan
Hunter in your previous position in the
White House I had to work with with them
yes slightly because they were very
important to appropriating money for
some of our counterterrorism programs
what is your opinion of the gentleman
that and ladies that you worked with in
Congress I think by and large they're
hard-working there are some who
perhaps need to work a little harder but
if you look at the 535 members of
Congress you'll find an awful lot of
people up there who are really expert in
their issues and spend very very long
hours working on their issues
Kendyl florida you're on the air with
richard clarke go ahead miami long
enough to do that civil discourse which
i really wish would develop in this
country but since 9/11 I've gone back
and tried to read more books about the
Middle East I've tried to understand
more about Al Qaeda I've read or heard
how Bill Clinton tried to deal with the
Terrorism that he had to deal with I do
think it's not credible to suggest he
could have declared war but when I make
the comparison between Clinton's actions
to bring out more evidence and Bush's
apparent actions to suppress evidence it
seems to me possible to come to the
conclusion that Bush wanted the attack
to happen as an excuse for war and I'm
wondering if from your experience you
could give me some specific facts not
not the general belief George Bush is a
noble honorable man and he wouldn't
deliberately let an attack occur I don't
think he or anyone else in his
administration expected planes being
flown into the tree Twin Towers although
other people knew that was a possibility
but is there anything that would weigh
the thigh that he wouldn't have let that
happen
well I think there is this broad
conspiracy theory out there that
the Bush administration let the attacks
happen the fact is they didn't know the
attacks were going to take place not in
the United States CIA had told the
president that attacks were probably
coming but CIA said those attacks will
probably occur overseas and we did all
we could do overseas to heighten
security at US embassies and military
bases domestically we didn't know an
attack was coming domestically but even
if we did there are so many facilities
to protect that there wasn't a great
deal we could do without more
information I'm pretty confident that if
we had that information the president
would have acted we didn't have that
information my complaint is that the
president being told that something was
about to happen did nothing to try to
shake the trees to find out what was
about to happen
mr. Clarke did this book have to be
cleared by the CIA or anyone any book I
write for the rest of my life has to be
cleared by the government for security
purposes to make sure I'm not revealing
anything that is still classified did
you have to take anything out of the
original draft out of the scorpions gate
no are them against all enemies afraid I
did
last call Lake Bridgeport Texas your
honor
okay yeah there there
I'm just I'm just
caller we're gonna have to let you go we
are out of time I apologize for that so
thanks for trying anyway so Richard
Clark is the author of the scorpions
gate in fact just a minute he'll be
talking to that audience behind him in
Chapman auditorium here on the campus of
miami-dade College in downtown Miami mr.
Clark thank you thank you very much and
we will be going to that event in just a
minute or so as soon as mr. Clark gets
up on stage we'll give him a chance to
unbuckle and and then we'll listen to
him talk to the audience and take
questions from the audience there we've
got about Oh an hour and a half or so an
hour 45 left in our live program
programming today here at the Miami Book
Fair International after mr. Clark we
will speak with Umberto fontava he has a
new book out Fidel Hollywood's favorite
tyrant we'll be talking about Fidel
Castro and us Cuban policy and then at
3:00 p.m. Eastern Time this afternoon
there is a live event live panel
discussion on science and inventors
allan lichtman rebecca goldstein and
david levitt would be on that panel and
that runs from about 3:00 p.m. Eastern
Time to 4:15 Eastern Time and we'll
bring that to you live while mr. Clark
is getting ready to speak we want to
show you around the fair here in
downtown Miami
done
there
okay
here I gave you five back
they were just in there comparing middle
names mr. bard is the deputy world
editor of the Miami Herald please
welcome him
good afternoon richard clark entered the
national consciousness in 2004 after
publication of his non-fiction book
against all enemies it soon climbed to
the top of the New York Times bestseller
list in that book he argued that the
Bush administration had failed to treat
the al-qaida threat as a priority before
the September 11th 2001 terrorist
attacks and that the invasion of Saddam
Hussein's Iraq undermine the war on
terrorism the ideas in that book have
become part of the debate over US
strategy in the battle against terrorism
and over the decision to invade Iraq
that national discussion is only
intensified as we have seen this past
week in the halls of Congress
publication of against all enemies came
after a career in Federal service that
spans some 30 years mr. Clark began his
Federal service in 1973 in the office of
the secretary of defense he has worked
for every president since Ronald Reagan
in the Reagan administration
he was Deputy Assistant Secretary of
State for intelligence under the first
president Bush he was Assistant
Secretary of State for political
military affairs and a member of the
National Security Council that was
followed by eight years as a special
assistant to President Bill Clinton and
George W Bush from 2001 until 2003 he
was a special adviser to the president
for cyberspace security and on September
11th after terrorists struck the United
States he found himself acting as crisis
manager in the White House in the
Situation Room he currently serves as
chairman of good
Consulting now mr. Clark has written a
work of fiction
and he says fiction can often tell the
truth rather than nonfiction
I'm pleased to welcome Richard Clark to
Miami and to the Miami Book Fair
thank you
thank you very much
it's a thank you
it's a pleasure to be here in Miami
today I appreciate that
please
thank you
thank you for that warm Miami welcome
and Richard thank you view that
introduction it's a it's a pleasure to
come here and talk about my first work
of fiction or if you believe the white
house my second work of fiction
as I was traveling around the country
last year talking about against all
enemies inside America's war on terror
an awful lot of readers urged me to
continue writing and they asked me to
continue writing because they they were
curious about what it's like to be in
those meetings in the White House in the
Middle East what it's like to go to
those places like the bunkers and the
intelligence centers but more
importantly the second reason they
wanted me to continue to talk about the
Middle East and our relationship with it
and I thought you know I'd be glad to
continue that dialogue with the readers
but I'd like it to be a different set of
readers a more inclusive set of readers
now many of you might go to a bookstore
and pick up a non-fiction book on
foreign policy and national security but
most folks won't when I thought about it
if I didn't have to teach national
security I probably wouldn't read those
books either
what is it than I normally read
especially on a long flight across the
Atlantic which I'm taking tonight by the
way I'm going to Berlin tonight and the
answer is I don't really pick up a
thriller and when I thought about it I
have learned a lot by reading thrillers
now I recognize that some of the things
you read and thrillers aren't true
depends on the author but a lot of it is
and at least can raise issues and it can
raise issues in a way that sometimes
grabs the reader much more personally
than a nonfiction book so I thought back
to something we did a lot in the White
House called tabletop exercises or
visualization exercises here's what we
would do
we would get the cabinet members
together or the deputy cabinet members
and put them around a u-shaped table
with a screen up front and usually me in
the middle with a microphone pretending
to be Geraldo Rivera and we would say to
the cabinet members all right suspend
disbelief a moment it's a few years from
now here are the changes that have
occurred in the two or three years now
that we're in the future but basically
everything is the same aside from these
few changes now we're going to give you
a crisis and you're going to act like
the cabinet like the National Security
Council would even at play yourself
and react to the crisis so one crisis
for example we said the FBI has just
learned that there is a nuclear bomb on
board a yacht
it's hide up at Maine Avenue in
Washington the main avenue was about a
mile from where we were meeting in the
White House and they sort of looked at
that and thought about it and then it
was my job to take the microphone and
put it in the face of Janet Reno and say
all right Attorney General what are you
going to do about it and the meeting
would flow from there and they had to
make decisions as though it was the real
world and the controllers of the game
would react to their decisions to keep
presenting them with a series of plot
twists and turns if you will so that
they were simulating the experience of a
real crisis it grabbed them every single
one of them got into the game and
started worrying about how they were
going to stop that nuclear bomb from
going off and we presented them with all
of the tough questions that they would
have to face in the real world now the
reason we did that was so that God
forbid they ever had to face
that reality of a terrorist with a
nuclear weapon in the nation's capital
they would have already done it it would
be that much easier for them because
they would already have thought through
the issues under a little bit less
pressure than if it were actually
happening because we did those games
when September 11th happened and I was
thrown into the role of crisis manager I
didn't have to think too hard about the
steps that we had to execute because we
had exercised and exercised and
practiced and practiced so there was a
real world value to these visualization
exercises but the other value was that
the cabinet members would usually go
back to their departments after the
exercise assemble their key staff and
say I don't ever want to have to face
that kind of event in the real world
what can we do now to prevent that sort
of thing from happening and because of
that the Clinton administration and the
Bush administration initiated a series
of programs that came as a result of
playing these exercises and the cabinet
members saying boy we have to make sure
that never happens so I thought wouldn't
it be good if I could write a thriller
that used that same technique that said
it's the real world but it's five years
from now and here are the things that
have changed not much and many of the
things that are troublesome now have
gotten more in troublesome we've
extrapolated real world events and the
purpose is twofold one to bring the
reader into those meetings behind closed
doors into those crisis rooms into the
back alleys of the Middle East but to
to leave the reader asking how can we do
things now so that we don't have to face
that kind of world five years from now
so let me tell you a few of the trends
that are extrapolated in scorpions gate
the first is our dependence on foreign
oil Middle Eastern oil and how our
dependence on Middle Eastern oil
transforms and distorts our foreign
policy and our national security policy
right now we're the world's largest
importer of oil number two however is
China and China is increasing its rate
of imports more rapidly than we are as
the world's oil reserves draw down the
United States and China as the two
largest oil importers in the world will
be competing for the same oil supplies
now hopefully that competition will be
peaceful but what if it's not already in
the real world of 2005 the Deputy
Secretary of State Robert Zoellick has
said recently that we're troubled by the
fact that China seems to be trying to
get exclusive oil deals exclusive oil
deals for the countries in the Middle
East in scorpions gate they are trying
to get a very exclusive oil deal with
the largest producer of oil in the
Middle East and that would be Saudi
Arabia the novel opens in 2010 18 months
after the Royal House of Saud has been
overthrown now is that possible the
thing the government of Saudi Arabia
could be overthrown it's possible think
back to 1979 when our best friend in the
Middle East and the guy who was selling
us all the oil was the Shah
of Iran the head of the house of pavlova
the royal house in Persia and we would
ask the Shah and his government how
stable is the government how popular is
the Shah we'd like to go around Iran and
find out using the CIA using the State
Department and the Shahs government
always said no no you can't do that but
we'll we'll tell you the answers
everybody loves the Shah the Shahs
government is very stable and then we
woke up one day in 1979 and the Shah was
out and the ayatollahs were in and we
weren't getting any oil from Iran
anymore well there's the potential for
that in Saudi Arabia the Saudi royal
family the 2,200 princes big family the
Saudi royal family doesn't want us
wandering around either the CIA or the
State Department wandering around Saudi
Arabia trying to find out how stable
they are how popular they are they tell
us to rely on them and they'll tell us
they tell us everybody loves the King
and everybody loves the royal family and
yet every month or so we see some
incident where people are shooting at
each other in Jeddah or Riyadh for 18 or
20 hours where some major terrorist
attack has occurred so we know that
there is some opposition we know that 15
of the 19 hijackers on September 11th
came from Saudi Arabia and the US Army
is now reporting that the majority of
the foreign fighters who are showing up
in Iraq and certainly the majority of
the suicide bombers in Iraq are Saudi
and we know that the CIA is reported
that many people are going to a
RAK learning how to become terrorists in
Iraq training by attacking our soldiers
and then many of them are going home and
creating terrorist cells and spreading
their expertise at making bombs and
attacking soldiers therefore many of
them must be going home to Saudi Arabia
I don't think it's therefore that hard
to extrapolate that five years from now
we could be facing a situation where the
House of Saud has fallen so scorpions
gate opens the House of Saud has fallen
and is so often in revolutions the
French Revolution the Russian Revolution
people United to get rid of the
government in power and then when they
got rid of the government in power they
discovered they all didn't agree with
each other and so the people who threw
out the House of Saud are struggling to
see who will dominate the new Saudi
Arabia will it become an al Qaeda like
government or could it be more moderate
more democratic more representative of
the people the other trend that I'm
extrapolating in scorpions gate is
what's going on with Iran you know I
used to talk to audiences before
September 11th and talk about the danger
of al Qaeda and people were almost in
every audience as I said al Qaeda for
the first time you could see people in
the audience turning to each other and
saying who what's that people hadn't
heard about al Qaeda
well now they haven't heard about alkyds
Qod s o Kurds the Qods force hoods in
Farsi and in Arabic means Jerusalem
hoods force is a real secret
intelligence paramilitary organization
run by Iran he blew up the Jewish
centers in Buenos Aires
in the real world it blew up the US Air
Force Base at Khobar Saudi Arabia and
it's now sending thousands of its agents
into Iraq so that when we leave which
ultimately we will the Iranians will
have a great deal of influence in the
new state of Iraq
I haven't seen very much written in the
unclassified open literature about the
Kurds forced and so I told you I tell
you in scorpions gate as much as I can
about goods force and what I think it
has done the way I think it acts and
operates that - is a force that we can
extrapolate forward about five years the
final trend that we see today that plays
out in scorpions gate is the problem
that military officers have and
professional diplomats professional
intelligence officers have career people
not partisan not political appointees
career people experts with 20 or more
years of service the problem that they
have when they realize that their
government is making mistakes when they
realize that some people in their
government are covering things up
from the people and from the Congress
what do they do when they think their
government is lying and that's something
that a lot of people in the US
government today are struggling with so
not a lot of our military are struggling
over whether or not they can come
forward and say what they believe
without risking their pensions their
careers and their families
you'll see in scorpions gate some of the
characters dealing with that conundrum
that moral and ethical and professional
conundrum
scorpions gate has about five major
characters they don't know each other as
the book begins
they each uncover a little piece of the
jigsaw puzzle of what is about to happen
if they can all meet and if they all
then are willing to exchange the
information that they have they can put
together the jigsaw puzzle and they can
see what's about to happen now what's
about to happen could change the entire
nature of the Middle East if they can
get together and if they can find that
out is there anything that these five
people can do to stop it from happening
because the clock's ticking and a major
event is about to go down
that's the plot I'll leave it to you to
figure out if they get together
and I will leave it to you to figure out
if they can stop it I hope for those of
you who read scorpions gate that it will
tell you a little bit about what it's
like in these occupations and tell you a
little bit of the issues that we face
now and the background the historical
background to how we got here but also
preview for you what I think are going
to be issues that we will face in the
next five years so thank you very much
for coming
and will be will be glad for the next
few minutes until I get hooked off the
stage here to answer a few questions yes
sir after your delivery and that was
called trust it seems as though it would
require trust yet how is the government
supposed to should we say get responses
when the aunt public answers may be
aiding what we describe as the enemy or
see as the enemy yeah it's a tough
question that the government has
frequently in the past hidden behind a
statement that we can't tell you
everything because it would help the
enemy it's almost never true the enemy
knows all the enemy needs to know to do
what they're doing I mean it reminds me
of the charge that if the American
government has a public discussion about
when we should start the withdrawal from
Iraq then the terrorists will be
emboldened I never understood that logic
either I mean the terrorists are
emboldened
it's not as though the terrorists are
holding back you know something that
they could do and then they're gonna say
oh my god the Congress is discussing
when to leave Iraq let's attack
something I don't think that the kinds
of things that the public needs to know
to participate in a public discussion of
our national security in any way helps
the enemy the level of detail that would
help the enemy is generally not
necessary for this kind of discussion
then why no trust well Trust is a
two-way street I think the American
people tended to trust their government
in recent years I think in the last two
years as more people have realized that
their government distorted the truth
that trust has eroded and it's going to
take a long time for us to get it back
yes sir I enjoy reading your first book
against all enemies I'm looking forward
now to reading your new novel I wanted
to ask you what it was like being the
target of the Republican smear machine
when you first revealed that Bush had
ignored all your warnings about 9/11 and
al-qaida and do you think that people
are beginning to see through their
tactics now that everyone who comes up
and criticizes them is either accused of
being unpatriotic up anyone who
criticizes their policies is accused of
being an American do you think people
are starting to see through these
tactics and start to question the source
itself yeah you know senator Hagel was a
Republican Chuck Hagel said the other
day that it's it's not on patriotic to
question our policies it's unpatriotic
not to
whether you agree with our policies in
Iraq or on the war on terrorism or not I
think you have to believe if you're an
American that policy should be subject
to regular open discussion in the press
and in in forums and in the Congress
that's the way we've done it for 200
years and it's kind of worked
we should not abandon that now and when
the president says well you can't
question my policies because that'll
hurt our troops and that's just not true
I think people see through the tactic of
attacking the critics when for example
you look at the pattern you know this
week we had a man who served in the
Marine Corps for 30 years over 30 years
at the Bronze Star for combat two blue
two Purple Hearts for having been
wounded in combat and he stood up and
said I don't think our policy in Iraq is
working and people called him a coward
people who've never put on the uniform
people who've never served in the
military never risked their lives in any
way shape or form you know that's just
wrong and it was wrong when Max Cleland
the senator from Georgia was running for
re-election and the smear machine said
he was unpatriotic I don't know if you
all know about max but he lost three of
his four limbs fighting for this country
and the audacity of anyone to say that
Max Cleland was unpatriotic is
outrageous
so I think it's it's beginning to
backfire you know I think people are
beginning to see through the attack the
attacker don't talk about the issues
don't talk about the substance but
attack the critic I don't think that's
working anymore and I hope as the
Republican White House smear machine
sees that it's not working
they'll stop it in my case they stopped
it after about a week or ten days when
they realized that they were selling my
book and I I could only wish that they
had kept it up for another week or two
yes sir
I would like to personally thank you for
having the courage to come forward when
you did to speak the truth and I feel
that there were really too few voices
expressing that point of view I'd like
to ask you there's a lot of debate right
now as to whether or not the president
and the Congress had the same
intelligence to go by and drew different
conclusions based on that same
intelligence and I'd like to ask you and
there's also a debate going on right now
as to whether or not if we were to pull
out which I think in the end we are
going to end up pulling out and it's
going to be a destabilized Iraq that we
end up leaving do you share that view
and if and what what do you think the
end result in Iraq will be well first of
all the the people of the White House
get very detailed intelligence they get
what we call raw intelligence so if a
spy somewhere says something they get
that specific report if we hear
something being broadcast they get the
transcript they get the satellite
picture what the Congress gets is
analysis imagine all of this raw
intelligence coming down into a funnel
and dropping on the desk of an analyst
and the analyst has to
what's going on what's true what's false
because just because we collect
something doesn't mean it's true and
then put that together and draw a
conclusion the Congress by and large
gets the conclusion they don't get the
actual material and so for example in
this famous now famous or infamous case
of intelligence that said that an
African country was selling uranium to
Iraq
so that Iraq could build a nuclear
weapon
Congress was told that in the National
Intelligence Estimate but they never
actually got to see the document that
said that now most of you if you saw the
document would realize it was a forgery
it was pretty bad pretty bad forgery
that's the difference Congress doesn't
get to see the the source information if
you will know with regard to Iraq if we
withdraw
will there be chaos yeah there's chaos
now and we're seeing upwards of eighty
to a hundred attacks a day against
coalition forces that's about double
what it was when the vice president said
the insurgency was on its last legs
yeah I suspect whenever we withdraw
there will be chaos and that's the point
whenever we withdraw whether we withdraw
in 2007 or we withdraw in 2010 there
will be some period of chaos much as
there is today the question is how long
will that chaos last what will the
outcome be and do we really change that
by staying in my view there will be some
chaos when we pull out and then the
Iraqis will stabilize their own country
you know they'll get a modus vivendi
going among the factions and I don't see
the point in delaying until 2010 or 2012
because if we hang
for that long we will kill a lot more
American soldiers and we'll kill a lot
more Iraqis and I don't think the
difference will be appreciable whether
we withdraw in 2007 or 2012 so having
done that analysis I think we ought to
get out in 2007 thanks I read the first
book which I enjoyed a lot
two things that maybe you could speak to
number one was the bin Laden flight I'd
like to hear some comment on that and
then the relationship between the bushes
and prince Bandar who I understand is no
longer in DC by the bin Laden flight you
mean the flight of the bin Laden family
members after September 11th you know
there's been one of the minor
controversies coming out of the 9/11
investigation is the question of why did
we allow Saudi royal family members and
bin Laden's family members to leave the
United States after the attack they
requested the Saudi embassy requested
permission to evacuate some people who
they thought would be at risk you have
to understand the bin Laden family is
enormous
there are 20-something sons huge family
most of the family almost all of it is
reputable they're business people some
of them have been in the United States
doing business for years and we know
that because we kept an eye on them as
you can imagine if your name was bin
Laden then you were living in the United
States even in the 1990s we probably
have a very good idea what you were
doing every day and who you were talking
to know what you were saying so when the
Saudi embassy wanted to evacuate some
royal family members and some bin Laden
family members a request came to me at
the White House and I said yes provided
that the FBI cleared every individual
and said that they didn't want to talk
to any of those individuals before they
got on the plane and the FBI looked at
the list and they knew a lot about all
the people on the list and decided that
they didn't need to talk to them and so
they left had I thought to do over again
I'd probably do the same thing I don't
see any downside to the fact that they
left it turns out that now four years
later the FBI still doesn't want to talk
to them so I don't think we've missed
any opportunity there as regard to the
relationship between the Bush family and
the Saudi prince who was their
ambassador in Washington very very close
very very close unusually close and that
turned out to be a good thing in the
first Gulf War but I think over time it
turned out probably to give us only one
side of what was going on in Saudi
Arabia yes sir something I hope you can
support but not support and they
supports some of the things you've said
before and that is first that the
world's production of oil is going to
peak around 90 million barrels a day
predicted by many geologists it's based
on Hubbard's theory as you know and
where they predicted United States would
peak in 1970 indeed we did and that's
one point and by the way last year we
produced about 84 million barrels of oil
so 90 is real close to what the world is
now producing number two we get about 70
percent of our oil from the Middle East
from those five countries in the Middle
East and I really hate to say it I
really feel that is one of the storm
motivations but what's happening now in
the Middle East our strong attention to
the yeah well you're right to point out
that when oil Peaks which is to say when
we reach the halfway point and the oil
that's in the world is a matter of some
controversy and the Saudis among the
many things they don't let us do is to
go in and independently verify how much
oil they actually have in the ground so
we're we're basing our assumptions on
their data
about how much oil they've got left and
oil no oil is fungible so that if any
one source of oil gets cut off from the
world supply people buy it elsewhere on
the spot market the point I'm trying to
make in the book is that we're not
serious about alternative energy
supplies there's a lot of things that we
could do today with existing technology
with ethanol you know if you go to
Brazil they're driving around with cars
that work perfectly fine on sugar cane
created fuels so we don't have to have
you know nuclear fusion in order to
solve our energy problem there's a lot
that we could do today that we're not
doing and I just don't think we're
serious about it and if we continue to
rely on market forces to dictate to the
outcome we'll be paying seven dollars a
barrel at some point in the future you
know we subsidize so many things in this
country we subsidize a few rich people
who grow peanuts and a few rich people
who grow rice and sugar absolutely but
we won't subsidize the cost of fuel by
underwriting let's say an ethanol
program and as a result of that they
have been to oil wars our war in 1990-91
in Kuwait was an oil war and the war
that we're going through now in Iraq is
an oil war and we'll continue to have
them until and unless we reduce our
dependency on Middle Eastern oil
yes sir following up on the question
about intelligence each branch of the
military has their own Intelligence
Agency their war colleges the history of
that area before the Ottoman Empire how
did the administration so badly
underestimate what the what would happen
in Iraq after initial invasion I still
can't understand why they didn't see
this at all that's been going on for
centuries yeah well you're right to
point out that there are experts at the
war colleges and just as an example the
Army War College in Carlisle
Pennsylvania did a study saying what
would happen if we tried to occupy Iraq
and they predicted in great detail the
insurgency that would come about the
State Department with all of its Foreign
Service expertise also did a
multi-volume study before we went in
saying what would happen it's not that
the government doesn't have experts it's
that the White House wasn't listening to
them yes sir in your opinion how
important is the process of
democratization in the Middle East vital
to the fight against international
terrorism and as as a follow-up what
changes besides our dependence on
international oil resources which you
recommend making in foreign policy to
further that fight I think
democratization has gotten a bad name
because the United States started
talking about democratization after it
invaded Iraq and in many people's minds
in the Middle East the two have been
linked that's quite serious that if you
if you stand up you know in Egypt today
and say well let's talk about democracy
people are going to say oh you're an
American stooge I think it's unfortunate
that that's happened but it has happened
and while we want democracy for every
country in the world and we believe
democracy can work in every country in
the world they have to come at it at
their own pace and with regard to their
own traditions and history sometimes if
you push democracy too early or in the
wrong way
you won't like the results in Algeria
several years ago they held a democratic
election that essentially elected al
Qaeda and it's the local branch of al
Qaeda but it was Al Qaeda and the
military stepped in and voided the
election and frankly the United States
appreciated that some people like Robert
Baer who's written a series of books on
the Middle East say and and not just in
jest that if we held an election in
Saudi Arabia today bin Laden would win
we did hold an election in the
northwestern provinces of Pakistan last
year and Al Qaeda's outlawed in Pakistan
so al Qaeda didn't win but the people
who won looked a lot like Al Qaeda so
democracy yes eventually in some places
sooner and others but it has to bubble
up from the people it can't be inserted
at the point of a bayonet yes sir I'm
afraid that's gonna be the last question
because I do want to sign some books
before I get on the plane you're not
over limits aren't I can't wait to get
your fiction the one question that
puzzles me is that the Bush
administration has been extremely
successful in one area because it's
failed and balancing the budget it's
screwed up this war it's filed up on tax
policy whatever it is but they've been
very successful in changing the
perception of apparently a majority of
our fellow citizens as to how you tell
fact from fiction I really mean it and
karl rove our only hope as he goes to
prison but he has
he has been able really to get to the
dark side of so many people and get them
to vote for this guy idiot that I I
wonder how when you do your games future
games and then the extrapolation how and
whether you can extrapolate any of that
into the future you're absolutely right
I mean one point eighty something
percent of the American people in
opinion polls when asked if Iraq had
something to do with the 9/11 attacks
over eighty percent of the American
people at one point said yes
wherever did they get that idea could it
be that the President and Vice President
and other senior administration
officials kept saying it either
explicitly or implicitly well after the
9/11 Commission report said that it was
not true that Iraq had absolutely
nothing to do with 9/11 public opinion
turned around but there was still 30
something percent of the American people
who continued to say in response to the
opinion polls that Iraq had something to
do with 9/11 and that intrigued the
opinion pollsters as to why people still
believed it after it was disproven and
so they asked that group a series of
questions and the vast majority of the
people who continued to believe that
Iraq had something to do with 9/11 said
that their major news source was the Fox
News Network
so I I can understand how if you never
hear the alternative that you might
continue to believe things like that and
if you listen to certain radio and
television you'll ever hear the truth
about things that embarrass the
administration I think it's very
important in days like these that we
seek out media sources like the BBC and
The Economist like NPR and places where
you know you're getting the straight
story thank you very much for coming